welcome to this video game six coverage
of the World Championship match between
defending champion viswanathan magnus
carlsen from norway yeah the game six is
obviously very important as Carlton has
won Game five and some in the lead
before the game at the immediate game
after after that and island now with the
white pieces certainly needs to try
something to immediately level the score
again in a recent World Championship
matches in 2010 against to pawn off and
also in um 2012 he immediately managed
to ya to score when after he he lost the
game against galfond he lost them i'm
not mistaken game aight i think it was
gay made and then immediately struck
back the next day and all the next game
i think it was the next day really there
was no rest day between that and against
the Palo he lost the first game but
immediately won the second game so I'm
very important game today let's see what
happens was she playing efore and we
have the ROI again and we have the ball
in again the sims cards and some choice
for the match not going for is some
usually slightly more frequent choice of
basics he very often plays this mainline
room and I have a reason why I'm putting
this on the body's preferred line it's
night p8 the so-called prior variation
and TM already has played more than once
this against are not losing I think at
least one very nice game um ok but this
is far more complicated far more pieces
on the board then in the boolean end
game so it seems he has made the
conscious decision to play more
simplifying and just in general simple
alliance to avoid any possible home prep
and also try to steer the game more into
him his favorite channels like
simplified positions and more
strategically inclined positions okay
now important moment which is playing d3
not not the end game again and this is
already a slight ya mus a slight
concession and nod actually has an
excellent score at the end game but he
really didn't get anywhere and in the
game before that in game 4 so um d3 at
least put some yeah puts an end to the
immediate end game and get some into a
middle game that is more complicated
however this is not a move that like
really fierce I guess we should see five
normal move c3 yeah white can never
really win the spawn yeah why is that
look at f2 like cam can even play 24 not
even bishop f2 Queen D for the stronger
more threatening mate and attacking the
knight immediately winning so this is
not possible c3 actually prepares this
asset controls deform but I can still
cancel here you don't need to
immediately come right five if white
white plate castles but if white now
takes the pawn after beat takes Knight
xt5 black can play d5 and this has been
been tried before it's maybe not
immediately apparent but this is already
quite comfortable for black it's a
matter of development
White has lost some time with this pawn
grabbing operation and for instance 96
deceived outright bad because of Queen
e8 yeah the night needs to move the Deaf
it returns de form yeah Black has
regained the porn a threatening to take
with the temple and after cancelling
Bishop a six can you see that the All
Whites pieces on sleeping on the
queenside while black cam has everything
in play so you castle is just better and
now cars plays rook e8 he has played
mostly d6 before in this position but
rookie ages of course normal move it
covers c5 it doesn't commit t6 early are
now rook e1 normal-looking it's not the
most freaking move in the position but
gap the most normal move in the world so
why not preparing the standard Roman
over and over protecting e4 in case you
play d4 later this pawn might need some
protection okay a 6 Bishop a fall and b5
yeah black cam it's debatable if black
gum must play this move one point is if
you don't play this move and you go d6
then you always have to reckon with this
pawn push it's not entirely clear
actually but you don't really want to do
that so just be five is fine attacking
the bishop it reach eats and now the six
yeah this is a position that you can
easily compare to those arising from the
jungle trade show how the variation is
called this Bishop c5 line via three a6
sometimes quarter to catch a variation
or the niaga angles variation in those
kind of line c3 and d3 is not considered
especially dangerous but at least you
get a full game not simply finding to
then get
no I'm not plate and rather quickly
played Bishop g5 and it turns out that
this move was actually a novel team the
position he had been played a couple of
times before but Bishop g5 this new
night BTW to UM in fact had been played
before and yeah balanced against the
Levon Aronian earlier this year the
paris tournament this 11 lachlan back i
cannot pronounce that and this
tournament which was played in moscow
and then said petersburg in Paris yeah
I'm not BTW to but now Arnold is going
for Bishop g5 the typical pin the spin
now move gains a bit in strength after
the bishop is outside the pawn chain
simply because black has a hard time too
you have to remove this pin the bishop
would be on his head this isn't the
problem at all but yeah it's difficult
if you move the Queen somewhere like
here another good move anyway but what
will double the points you don't really
want to see that and get how to break
the pin that's not easy you can think
about this kind of maneuver but i'm not
sure that cars really wants to weaken
the queenside the King side so early
quite often this isn't a real problem
but um he took a while now to think and
then played Bishop to e6 funny enough
Bishop g5 is one of causes favorite
moves and the ruler PES so this is a bit
of bit cheeky to play this as a novelty
all right there should be six after
about 20 minutes so what took him a
while to decide on this and now on
unplayed night bg2 after some thought
and to be honest this sem
this some I find quite puzzling from
both sides actually because while it was
clear that if the Berlin is the main
choice against efore then d3 was
certainly moved that they needed to
reckon with and in this position are not
had reached before this position we
played Nabi to all right but certainly
Bishop she files a move that you should
check in your preparation especially
considering that Carson's playing Bishop
g5 all the time in the way so he is
himself very much aware of this move and
slowly took 20 minutes to play Bishop e6
and Allen then took 10 minutes for night
BTW to I mean Bishop e6 is not really a
spectacular move so it's a bit strange
to sit this time time usage they really
worked out things at the board or needed
to recollect something's hard to tell um
there to be honest I have firm some
problems with them with them
understanding um countenance opening
players its but it's a personal thing
thing because um yeah I play you 54 for
a long x black and I get those type of
positions all the time now we're
thinking okay well what what the heck is
why doing is simply not much happening
and gap in fact I think they're like
already has an equal game IAM don't see
any troubles of course it's it's not
easy to to find something great against
the number one to play on the world but
i don't know it feels like if this is
the big preparation to win a game it
feels a little bit a little bit weak um
maybe I'm some some entirely different
opening new phone would have been
interesting all right still it it's a
full game and Counting played age six
and took on b3 so
simplifying the position our laundry
captured eight xp3 this is the normal
way to recapture it makes sure that this
rook on a one has got something to do
and a double bond is not really an issue
um remember that I showed you the Brier
variation of the mainland Roy with my p8
here we go this is calvin smith and took
some minutes but then decided to
redeploy the night via be 8 27 this is a
very good maneuver i think and key thing
um our key maneuver that makes Blacks
game really easy now the point that it
is is a league-low loses some time of
course with the night be a 37 but the
knight on c6 was really not the world
place piece have a look it looks at
those two squares yeah they're both
protected it cannot really ever go to e7
because this is just unbelievably ugly
and also bad so the night can never
really go anywhere and if the Queen
moves we have this kind of business the
pin is still a problem and yeah
what-what else to to make sure you get
rid of the pin g5 has lost lots of
appeal after the lightscribe bishops of
weakening those squares so yeah this is
just a good move it really ploys the
night and make sure that you don't have
any issues with the spin and I think
here it's simply an equal position now
somebody not much going on I have a hard
time to suggest any big improvements for
white it's it just seems like there's
nothing going on he's playing on some
standard moves yeah this um we'll see
later this is
the idea of night h2 and now Magnus
deploys the Queen 22 v6 and this is also
very good maneuver and something to yet
to remember if you play the Royals plug
it's a very nicely placed only six
actually it goes out of any temples it
breaks the pin so now the knight on f6
is actually free to move and it also
keeps an eye on this slightly weakened
porn so I'm quite comfortable already
yeah Anna not played before trying to
fix the pawn which immediately was
answered by a five black does not want
to risk them having a backward a porn
all the time so he just decides to get
rid of it and now night g-form yeah this
doesn't really lead to too much but yeah
it's hard to suggest improvements as
already mentioned Bishop to b6 and now
I'm Anand went for this simplification
he probably at this point was okay with
the draw the opening has some clearly
not brought any advantage so let's just
get on with it and make it raw he
probably was thinking jack okay some
traits and now if white would manage to
play 95 he even would be better but of
course this oops not this one check
there's a problem on f2 so not night f5
you played quindi for this some get
activates the Queen a bit and the Tesla
slides trap if black plays c6 which
would be quite a good move to control d5
white has the good move Queen d7 which
attacks those
of points wide is clearly better am so
black cannot play c6 buddy has a simple
and good solution just hack this night
off f take see of course no other move
here and Queenie 7 just just a good move
all simple nothing fancy but they're all
strong and good Queenie 7 yep getting
out of the FR and commentators were
suggesting Queenie 6 mostly a of course
it's it's dead equal after that but well
by now you know what causes is thinking
I cannot really lose the game why should
I make it raw and it will simply play on
and why it has a very slight weakness
with this doubled pawns it's nothing
yeah nothing serious really but it is a
slight weakness and of course after the
win in Game five it's certainly also
matter of smelling blood if you know the
other side is some somewhat weak
somewhat shaken that's a good idea to
try to to use it I don't I want to bring
up this image of the wounded tiger which
is okay so Brooke everyone using the f
are trying to use it and c5 this is also
one point of this earlier knight c6
retreat you want to use the C porn and
now it's time to do so c5 King edge too
it's just nothing move okay but there's
nothing to do here and now see for this
is a typical way to try to fight against
those parts because now what it needs to
do something with the deep on it cannot
stay down and if it moves c4 will be
weak so you play deform the right move
and now we see that efore is the
weakness that like an attack always
based on the fact that you can at some
point take here and here in fact Carlton
played them
play drug trade and now queen bee 7 here
yall already could calculate this kind
of line like has one upon but this is
not the end of the world if we em if we
consider for example luque a check check
you see that white immediately regains
the porn so this is just too early to
take their fork will be seven intending
to take and then take probably only four
with the rook yeah in this position now
Allen played the rookie won he just
stays so to say sits tight and defenses
in this position here also d5 was
possible I'm not sure what is the prob
what what the problem with this move is
it still um doesn't change much in this
position black is still slightly more
comfortable but i don't know i think
that it's difficult now for black to get
anything again that gets the pawns and
after a look trade I don't know this
looks for instance ruka it looks like
Jack nothing because of this Queen
activation so r uu ka that probably
isn't maybe black can play something
slow with g6 I don't know i think the
fight was a pretty decent defensive try
but and Allen's place not really a bad
Jam it's um not not happening much okay
those are weak but it's basically just
one weakness I mean you can you could
argue that this is a weakness and this
is a weakness both points to weaknesses
but all this is just one complex lattice
week and one weakness usually it's not
enough to lose a game so nothing
terrible yet has happened of course it's
a bit uncomfortable
to have this position as wide after you
started the game with the ambition to to
try to level the score those little
improving moves g6 King to g7 and black
has all the time in the world yeah and
in this position and this is quite yeah
quite typical I think that people even
the best players in the world have
problems sitting on in on a slightly
worse and inferior position and defend
passively probably the the easiest way
probably to draw a 3 to do nothing just
play let's say kinking somewhere king
here or something and just stay and let
black do something it's not easy at all
for black to improve you can try this
green here and so on but how do you
really make any progress i don't i don't
see it um analysis it however is very
human um so it's um it's not a bad move
actually but it changes the game he
gives up the e4 pawn yeah but in the
meantime or in this process also
exchanges quedes and in fact with the
rookie on d5 attacking the b5 porn White
has gained some activity so they're
basically was a trade of the two week
pawns against the d6 poor and white in
the process gained activity so it's
really a good trade like needed to
protect and rock t6 activating further
yeah page form yantian maybe black
should have played age 5 p.m. let's it's
me maybe maybe the slightly a stronger
move but hard same um can play the King
f7
and after that and interestingly enough
played h5 sacrificing another pawn so
that his two points down um it's
probably in okay move he also could have
played anymore on a less forcing fashion
it's a it's not bad to just play
whoopsie six I think maybe it was afraid
of rookie seven yeah the thing is h5 is
still ok but you try to look for
improvements of course ok black cat took
it this is better than g5 after g5 this
whole complex is weak and you even have
to reckon with this King Marchan so not
a good move just take it two pawns are
two points even if the Pawn structures
slightly wrecked ok whoopty five yeah we
see that black is tied to this pawn how
is he going to make any progress not
easy f5 and King edge right now thousand
as usual does everything to continue the
game and try to set problems he just
jettisons the beep on try to activate
the rook and of course the white needs
to take it no D beta he took the pawn
can't black now in four for the porn got
the activity the look not only for is
really doing things and not just
defending upon passively so just just
well played I think but still there is
not much happening why displaying would
be eight and actually Bates the Rope
here to give checks from the back rank
and after King age five we I think have
a critical position now on because I
believe that was another moose he Jeep
later okay
8mm which is not spoiling much but to me
it seems that rook c8 is the easier way
to to play just keeping the pawn on c4
attacked and asking black ok how are you
going to make any progress here a few if
black plays a king moves there's the
check again and of course after King at
five we would have had the draw black
can go forward but it's not clear that
this is really helping if white just
returns to attack the seaport at some
point you even threatened to to take the
h-bomb and again if the King moves back
we have have a repetition again I think
that this was the stronger way to defend
this still is ok but it allows a final
try and this is Carla's really
outstanding ability besides many others
that he keeps finding things in
positions that are looking completely
dead and again he's finding some things
here that really don't yeah that really
are not apparent to the to the yeah I'm
yeah even given two very strong
opponents just just like that okay rook
f4 and the idea we see we see soon black
now gets to play check this maneuver
which wouldn't have been possible and
the other set up because then the white
rook always attacked the Seaport as
mentioned nothing terrible has happened
yet but black has made slight progress
check the check and the King invaded
this was the idea but at first you think
a white is this really good what about
rook c8 this was played attacking the
palm and black has no way to defend the
pawn
today's game was the first game that I
had the opportunity to watch the live
broadcast and the two commentators I'm
too strong with GM susan polgar and i
actually forgot the name I'm sorry there
was an Indian Grand Master gun I think
it was wrong wish but I'm not one
hundred percent sure they didn't have
the names in there they and they
mentioned them but they didn't have any
any subtitles that that gave the names
um yeah they they also could work out at
first what what was going on but it's
it's a great idea what Magnus played
here because I have a look at this it is
attacked ok black plays King III or
played quickly look see form and f4 and
at first you think wait isn't this
terribly risky for black he's got those
three split pawns and white is got two
connected passers isn't this maybe even
risky for black and the great thing is
he absolutely perfectly calculated that
those pawns are not dangerous and in
fact in this position exactly this
position white only has one move to draw
it's really amazing absolutely with
computers nowadays you can really a
calculate this to the end with them the
human brain is also of capable but needs
some time obviously and it also needs to
be done as we experience now they only
move that draws here is before it's
probably in a way the most logical move
because you push your pawn immediately
but the amazing thing is that every
other move losses before draws and you
can I can give you the line h3 this is
the important point here black jettisons
the spawn and then retreat and say here
to free the f porn but now um his pawns
are quick enough to to get enough count
play white can go here this is just one
possible line it's hard to show them all
but the difference to the game is that
the rookie stays on the six rank and can
harass the king with checks and this
guarantee is the draw it's very
difficult enough for me to show all the
lines it's it's leading to a draw before
believe me if you have some time on your
hands you can try to to play out some
some sample lines however you already
guessed it Anna didn't play this he
played look a form and if you see in the
time yet about 30 minutes left and he
only spend a little more than a minute
and pretty quickly he recognized that he
made a terrible mistake with this move
certainly you're calculating something
something wrongly not not quite sure
what it was they didn't really manage to
ya in the press conference they didn't
ask that I mean it's a terrible job for
a journalist to ask that what on earth
did you miss them but it would have been
interesting to know just down to
understand better what what was going on
yeah after ok 4 h3 was played and throop
g6 and now they have porn runs and there
are no checks the rook is simply
stupidly placed on a for it cannot give
any checks and therefore white needs to
play a non helping move like c4 now they
have porn just runs lang there's no way
to prevent it you can you can check this
kind of idea check and that's it it
simply promotes no way to stop it yeah
he played before f2 and jam yeah it's
all very sad g1 after Luke g1 is
stoppable I mean said not not being a
yeah an objective here it's just a bit
sad to to see gets it's a bit comparable
to do to boxing maybe if you have two
great fighters fighting fighting for a
couple of rounds and then it's always
feels a bit sad to see one of them going
down at least it's my feeling if you
have done the idea that they both did
did fight well and then one of the mass
to lose yeah but this is a this is an
amazing feature of consoles play it out
of nothing he managed to create a
position where really before is the only
move drawing and this is just great I
mean it's out of nothing he created some
problem and Anna didn't didn't solve it
I mean here 30 said 30 minutes but it's
it's problem after problem after problem
and they they they don't manage to solve
them there miss opponents okay that
means some counsel is leading 442
leading by two games we have a rest day
tomorrow and then Game seven will be
played on monday Monday the 18th with
again are not having white this is the
color change in the middle of the match
we have 46 games played now out of 12
and obviously I'm not going to lie to
you the matches almost decided plus two
is very hard to to come back from and I
say the only chance is that some are
honored wins in the next game but I
don't do any and it won't really see not
really see it i think this game was
terribly from a terrible from a
psychologic psychological point of view
playing a 60 move when in a yeah the
position were not much was happening
really and then you you give it away on
so let's hope island plays a good game
game 7 to simply keep the metra
competitive I'm not saying you should
necessarily win there whatever but just
let's hope that is not breaking down
completely and we have some more
interesting games alright thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it I'll be
back on Monday with game seven coverage